keegan thompson is going to come after
you with a four pitch mix a four seamer
that averages 94 miles per hour cutter
that gets swings and misses on the curve
ball has a change up
typically keeps it in his back pocket
three and three with a 3.40
era in his five starts the earned run
average up over six so obviously looking
to improve on that
edmond
[Applause]
safe
and away we go
so edmond at first after the error on
the cubs second baseman it'll bring up
paul goldschmidt here comes the o2
and he got him swinging on a good sharp
breaking ball out number one so here's
tyler o'neill the left fielder the
payoff by keegan thompson got him
swinging on a good high fastball so
here's nolan aronado the cleanup man for
saint louis
aronado is out on strikes
after the lead-off error thompson fans
goldschmidt o'neal and arenado
impressively jake woodford a very good
september
and a big reason why the cardinals are
in this spot
in the rotation
last time out
five shutout innings got the win and a
2-1 victory over the brewers that was
in milwaukee
caught by paul goldschmidt
a rope but into the glove of goldie for
the first out two down schwindel at
first scoreless ball game contreras at
the plate
smack off the body of the pitcher it's
going to be a base hit
contreras is single safe at second
schwendale let's see if woodford is all
right he never fell down
as that ball struck him somewhere in the
upper body i couldn't tell exactly where
it got him i thought maybe he got glove
on it matt duffy from long beach
california 30 years old the 1-2 pitch
ground ball left side aronado will step
on the bag and no damage done we played
one inning and there's no score harrison
vader at the plate no score between the
cubs and cardinals
here's a swing and a miss strike three
number four for
keegan thompson the backup catcher
kisner
diving stop duffy gets up throws across
the diamond garden
great play matt duffy took a double away
from andrew kisner boney goes to first
alcantara down to second now keegan
thompson 0-2 pitch by jake woodford
ground ball back to jake out there the
turn double play
well what do you know
during this winning streak 18 double
plays
turned by st louis two quick outs for
the cardinals here in the third and
it'll be paul goldschmidt
goldie to center
way out of here gone
dead
center field at wrigley
one-nothing
st louis
home run number 31 and now is driven in
98 and the cardinals strike first
thompson has given up a solo home run to
goldschmidt a single to o'neill and now
a walk to oronato it'll bring out dylan
carlson
strike three called thompson gets out of
it his seventh strike out of the day
that's a new career high and ian halfway
lined out to vader in the first inning
24 home runs for half the 1-2 ground
ball goldie steps on the bag another one
the tag applied by nolan oronato
another double play started by paul
goldsmith now alcantara at the plate
sergio is all for one
down the left field line
fair ball bouncing into the stands
round rule double
ball game tied run scoring double by
sergio alcantra still just one out men
at second and third and david bodie at
the plate
ball to right it's going to get the run
in the catch by carlson
tagging is duffy here comes the throw to
the plate not nearly in time
cubs lead two to one david bodie an
opposite field sacrifice fly racing to
third alertly was alcontra
and a swing and a miss and the first
strikeout for woodford today cubs pick
up a pair and a lead we move to the
fifth and it's 2-1 wilson contreras is
coming up with ortega first two outs
and contreras
pops it up
where's carlson here he comes oh and he
made the catch sliding the wind playing
tricks with it maybe he didn't pick it
up off the bat
regardless the catch
cardinals have men at first and second
and just one away here in the sixth
vader hits one in the air to center
ortega going back on it still drifting
and makes the catch on the track
the runners tag and move up 90. that
will really carried ortega battling not
only the sun but the wind as well and
that's so allowed out that puts both
runners in scoring position two down
ground ball to the right side bode's got
it flips the first inning over we'll get
back to billy in a minute good job by
alzheime getting out of the jam cubs
still have the lead at 2-1 matcher
andrew kisner leading the top half of
the seventh inning off for saint louis
backhanded by our contra long throw good
throw
there aren't many shortstops in the
league that have a better throwing arm
than alcontra yeah he does he's got a
cannon now the cardinals have something
going with two outs in the top half of
the seventh inning tyler o'neil the left
fielder for the cardinals
ground ball left side alcantara goes to
first has to hurry does and gets him to
end the inning
cardinals don't score cubs still have
the lead one away eight then and cubs
clinging to a 2-1 lead
playable for duffy comes up throwing and
gets him so the cardinals have four outs
to go and harrison bader will back the
one
bader hits it out to deep left late
eating magic again
we're tied 2-2
with two outs in the bottom of the
eighth harrison bader launches number
15.
two on with nobody out tommy edmond
broke an over 13 with a hit his last
time up the 1-1
he is bunting
hoyer to first
and they get tommy
so decision time now for david ross with
runners at second and third in just one
down paul gets an intentional walk
bringing tyler o'neal to the plate
gets away
around score
and the cardinals have the lead heron
the ninth 3-2 pitch to o'neal here he
comes
o'neal chops it back to horner he
dropped it a run will score
and out at first o'neill and then makes
it a 4-2 st louis lead
newt barr off with contact and the
cardinals lead it four to two the
cardinals are looking to put an
exclamation point on a perfect road trip
and make it 16 consecutive wins 3-2
jet swing and he went it's a strikeout
of bodhi and the first down here in the
bottom of the ninth potential winning
run at the plate that's what they're
facing in schwendell the 1-0
swindle gets underneath it popped up
kisner late break but arnado falls and
it drops in they have a first play
though at third throw to second and it
ends at a double play what else
it's a double play
but you should have infield fly in this
situation and mike schill will get an
explanation here arenato slipping thank
goodness he's all right lands in fair
territory
and there you saw finally the uh the arm
was up for the infield fly
yeah
so tommy edmond he tags the runner here
so was time called at that point goldie
knew the situation because
you advance at your own risk the ball is
in play time should not have been called
you and now shield has been ejected and
now the runners advance how i don't know
to second and third and there's two away
and a base hit could tie it up vo2
[Applause]
it's the run
of 21.
sweet 16. and oh how sweet it is